ja hallo Christof hallo her ich hte eine
kleine Frage und zwar haben sie ja vor
paar Jahren glaube ich einen Song
gemacht für Kick den sie auch auf deren
Feier irgendwie gespielt haben nur ist
die Frage ist die nicht zu
peinlich ich meine wie K sein Geld
verdient welchen Machenschaften das W
jetzt gar nicht diskutieren aber ist
ihnen haben sie keine Grenze wo sie
sagen nee das mache ich
nicht das wir mich me interessieren das
wird mich auch interessieren ob ich eine
Grenze habe aber diese Grenze konnte
sich gar nicht er fragte mich eben ich
habe für Kick ah ja g KCK Geschichte
unsere vuhzeige Lady
Pot Frau Pot ist ihres Zeichens das
Aushängeschild von
Kick ich habe einen Song gesungen als
Werbung für Kick das ist etliche Jahre
her da gab es keine Vermutungen das
Kick
Kinderarbeit wenn ich da richtig
informiert bin dass das mal so
kolpotiert wurde
zu Hilfe ziehen lässt von den Ländern wo
sie herstellen lassen auch wenn Sie den
Auftrag bestimmt so nicht gegeben haben
logischerweise nicht dann können Sie
gleich
zumachen das wusste damals keiner und
mit
Verlaub wenn ich das Angebot bekomme
einen Titel der noch nicht mal schlecht
war als Werbung für deren private
Veranstaltung in einem Zell zu singen
wenn ich das nicht täte dann sollte ich
mir ein anderen Job besuchen es hat mir
auch noch Spaß gemacht und ich finde
auch Kick fand ich ganz toll warum weil
ich gesagt habe die Leute die nicht viel
Geld haben können zu Kick gehen ich ma
jetzt werbe
Jingle für Kick ich sollte eigentlich
mich mal wiederholen aber dann würde ich
mir wirklich überlegen ob ich was ma ich
wer dann vorher Verona Fragen die kennt
sich mit solchen Themen ja aus
ähm ich habe das dann gesungen es hat
mir Spaß gemacht und ich habe ach so das
woll ich sagen ich habe dann Gutscheine
bekommen ja also mir wäre wären andere
Sachen peinlich aber das ist mir nicht
peinlich es sei denn ich würde es jetzt
machen und ich würde damit in
Zusammenhang gebracht werden dass sie
immer noch das täten was sie angeblich
getan haben sollen denn ob es bewiesen
ist weiß ich nicht ich habe es n im
Spiegel gelesen und was mich auch ein
bisschen frppiert hat muss ich sagen
weil das finden wir alle nicht
gut